This is the Saint Sophia
Russian Orthodox Cathedral.
Less than a mile across town
— is (Joseph) “Stalin Park.”
The Winters are freezing cold. The economy,
dominated by oil. Strangely, this is not Russia.
This is China’s northwestern
province of Heilongjiang,
located just 50 miles above North Korea.
Not so long ago, this was the beating heart
of the Chinese economy. It supplied the hard,
physical resources — coal, oil, and gas
— the country needed to industrialize.
And thanks to its importance, the region basked
in the warm, golden glow of the Party’s favor.
This statue commemorates one of Mao’s
“model Socialist workers” nicknamed
“Iron Man” for his tireless
work on a nearby oilfield.
Then, one day, China moved on.
Sometime around 10 years ago,
the country changed focus.
Dirty, dangerous, and environmentally
destructive industries were out. Meanwhile,
technology, innovation, and
high-skill labor were in.
This was no polite suggestion. Nor was
this transition slow and methodical.
This sweeping economic restructuring was executed
with all the force and velocity of
an unchecked, authoritarian regime.
The message was unambiguous and unforgiving:
Robots are the future. Adapt or be left behind.
Foxconn — famous for assembling
the iPhone — began building what
it ominously called a “one-million robot army.”
Taxes were cut by 40% for tech companies.
And one province announced it would spend 70
billion dollars to replace workers with robots.
These were not empty threats…
In 2022, nearly 6 times more industrial robots
were installed in China than any other country.
And, by nearly every metric, this
transformation has been successful.
Between 2010 and 2020, its economy doubled
in size and its population grew by 76 million
people. China is bigger, stronger, and
richer today than it was a decade ago.
…But what’s often overlooked amidst this “Rise
of China” national renaissance
narrative is who was overlooked.
Not everyone was invited aboard this
high-speed train to modernity. By
very explicitly selecting new ‘winners’,
the Party dismissed others as ‘losers’.
Just as globalization favored coastal cities
like New York, Los Angeles, and San Francisco,
China’s new economic order favored rich urban
areas like Shanghai, Hangzhou, and Shenzhen.
Today’s “model Socialist
workers” are Tesla-driving,
high-rise-living data scientists and engineers.
Left behind are China’s West Virginias, Detroits,
and Pittsburghs — collectively
home to 100 million people.
These depressed cities remain frozen
in time — relics of an earlier era,
with their depleted oil fields
and Soviet-era Cathedrals.
In that same decade between 2010 and 20,
while most of the country was bursting at the
seams with growth, Heilongjiang actually shrank.
In 2021, just three and a half children were born
there for every 1,000 residents —
less than half the national average.
And if America’s Rust Belt was
forgotten, China’s was flat-out rejected.
While Americans are — at least legally — free
to pick up and move to new opportunities,
Chinese workers have no such luxury.
Because public services in China are
restricted to your place of birth,
these migrants can’t access healthcare, pensions,
or education in their new cities. Even their
children are banned from attending local schools.
In other words, those unlucky enough
to be born in China’s Rust Belt
today are permanent second-class
citizens in their own country.
So, here’s a puzzle: Why aren’t they angry?
Why, after being replaced by robots,
do these same workers maintain such
positive views about automation?
Out of 54 countries, China ranks
second-highest in agreement that
“more emphasis on technology is
a good thing” and fourth-highest
for “science and technology bring more
opportunities for the next generation.”
China is twice as optimistic
about the future as any other
country and six times as optimistic as the U.S.
Why?
Sponsored by Nebula, the exclusive home to
“China, Actually”, my seven-part Original series.
A lot has changed in China
over the last hundred years,
but one thing has not: its objective to
“catch up and surpass” the United States.
It’s hard to say where this competitive
mindset originates. But we do know that
Chinese leaders are big believers
in grand historical narratives.
Xi Jinping loves to repeat clichés like “the
East is rising and the West is declining.”
In the Party’s version of history, ‘Western’
imperialist powers once exploited their advanced
technology — firearms and naval instruments,
for example — to humiliate the Chinese empire.
The British stole Hong Kong, the Portuguese,
Macau, and the French, among others, Shanghai.
These traumatic chapters, it seems, led
Chinese leaders to view history as a one-way,
zero-sum, linear ‘race’. A
race it’s currently losing.
To overtake the U.S., therefore,
it needs to somehow accelerate — to
employ some kind of “force multiplier.”
China calls this “overtaking on a
bend”. While a more cautious driver
like Washington might slow down as it
approaches a sharp curve in the road,
Beijing, on the other hand,
must fearlessly accelerate.
Until recently, this meant overlooking the
consequences of rapid industrialization. If
America enforced labor laws, China saw its
asymmetrical advantage as ignoring them.
A culture of “build fast and
break things” at a national scale.
It also meant quickly and
indiscriminately adopting
Western technology — especially
after Mao’s death in the 1970s.
The Party, at the time, faced a serious problem:
On one hand, everyone could see that Mao’s
Great Leap Forward had been an unmitigated
disaster — accomplishing little and
killing millions in the process.
On the other, it certainly couldn’t condemn its
own founder and ‘hero’ — the
literal face of the Party.
Ultimately, the way it lawyered itself out
of this embarrassing dilemma went like this:
While Mao’s goals were noble,
his methods may have been flawed.
With a few tweaks here and there,
China would be back on track.
The Communist Party was still relevant
because only it had the scientific and
technocratic expertise to make those adjustments.
Its performance would now be based more on
its material than its ideological success.
And this ‘success’ would largely be
measured by the number of smartphones
in people’s hands, robots on factory
floors, and miles of high-speed rail.
In the process, technology took
on an almost supernatural aura. It
became the “magic bullet” to all of China’s
problems — its state religion, if you will.
Naturally, this led to lighting-fast
adoption. The country went straight from
cash to mobile payments, from fax machines
to iPhones. In its quest to catch up,
it skipped right over checks, credit
cards, pagers, and Blackberries.
But this infatuation with technology also made it
vulnerable to digital snake oil —
waste, fraud, and false promises.
To see why, watch how all
this plays out on the ground,
as these grand aspirations trickle down through
the Party's 40-million-person bureaucracy…
First, Xi Jinping wakes up one day
and declares “Robots are the future!”
But although his authority is unlimited,
his ability to execute this vision is
limited — he himself can’t make
or buy or regulate these robots.
The Central government, therefore, delegates the
‘how’ to its ‘what’ down to local governments.
To incentivize their cooperation,
Beijing promotes and demotes these
officials based on quantifiable metrics
— say, how many robots they install.
And, eager to get that corner office,
boy, will they install some robots!
As a rule, when China’s goals are easily measured
— file more patents, graduate more engineers,
or produce cheaper solar panels — you can
pretty confidently bet on its success.
Indeed, as you can see, digital
technology has grown from 14% of
its economy in 2005 to a remarkable 39% in 2020.
That’s what China is good at. These
incentives allow it to go from napkin
sketch to completed skyscraper in no time flat.
But! When its goals are intangible or
more subjective — like winning hearts
and minds around the globe — it tends to struggle.
It’s easy to build more robots. It’s a lot
harder to make sure they’re put to good use.
Now, make no mistake: much of this
39% of China’s economy is productive.
As the government dumped billions of dollars
worth of subsidies on the tech sector,
some of it landed on your Huawei’s,
your TikTok’s, your Xiaomi’s.
But for every TikTok, there are 10 million
terminally-unprofitable metaverse startups.
For every Huawei, there are 20 billion
nebulous “smart city” initiatives.
You name a gimmick, scam, or buzzword,
and the Chinese government has almost certainly
invested an alarming number of zeros in it.
Last July, for instance, the city of Shanghai
announced it would spend over one
billion dollars on the metaverse.
A few years earlier, this “futuristic
bus” went viral for “solving” the problem
of gridlock by gliding over traffic.
Unfortunately, it was later exposed as
a pyramid scheme — but not before 5 Chinese
cities signed contracts with the company.
Now, no country is immune to misplaced
optimism. Remember Solar Roadways?
In fact, who pioneered the metaverse
craze but Facebook — an American company!
But if Silicon Valley wins the award for
inventing the most cutting-edge snake oil,
China wins the award for buying the most.
Time after time after time, China
eagerly imports these wasteful,
speculative “innovations” and then proceeds
to dig the deepest possible money pit.
Part of the problem is that private companies take
advantage of the government’s faith in technology.
Why would they question the usefulness of all
these gadgets when they’re being handed
billions of dollars worth of subsidies?
Assessing the utility of cutting-edge
inventions is hard enough. Doubly so for
a 70-year-old with no technical background.
And triply so when you’ve constructed an
intricate bureaucracy of 40 million yes-men
with no incentive to give negative feedback.
As a result, it takes a long time for reality
to catch up with the country’s leaders.
And, therefore, when it finally does, it often
provokes a swift and brutal overcorrection.
Recall that it began shifting focus from
heavy industry to tech sometime around 2010.
For the next decade, China’s Silicon Valley
enjoyed its moment in the spotlight — it,
like coal, oil, and gas before
it, basked in the Party’s favor.
Companies like Baidu, Tencent, and
Alibaba exploited this boundless
enthusiasm and cheap capital
to grow bigger and bigger.
They started making riskier bets. They entered
wildly unrelated markets. And their
CEOs became dangerously popular.
Then, after 10 years, the fun
came to a screeching halt as
the Party realized the monster it had created.
And in 2020, it sprung into action,
breaking up the largest companies and
regulating them like never before.
To be clear: the Party hasn’t
lost its faith in technology.
This crackdown was about steering
the industry toward what it calls
“high-quality” or “productive” growth. Think less
internet gambling and Fortnite and loan sharks,
and more semiconductors, EVs, and robots.
In fact, China really has no choice
but to double down on technology.
In 2021, its population began to shrink.
And this decline is especially pronounced
among the working-age — those roughly 18 to 65.
Meanwhile, Chinese labor — once among the
cheapest in the world — is now four times
as expensive as neighboring countries
like Thailand and the Philippines.
Unsurprisingly, many companies have responded by
shifting their production to those cheaper places.
Each year, fewer and fewer Chinese
workers are employed in manufacturing.
All these factory workers have
to find new jobs somewhere.
And tech is one of the few
areas of growth. As you can see,
the decline in manufacturing has coincided with
a rapid rise in labor-intensive service jobs.
These are your Uber drivers, your live-streamers,
and your DoorDash delivery people.
So, that’s why the government must
continue embracing technology. But
this still leaves one important
question: Why do workers?
After all, the jump from assembling iPhones to
delivering meals isn’t all
that great of a promotion.
These are still low-paid and
surprisingly dangerous jobs.
Because delayed orders are heavily penalized,
for example, Chinese delivery people are
prone to extremely reckless driving. Serious
injuries and even deaths are shockingly common.
Never mind that these aren’t, strictly
speaking, “jobs”. They’re independent
contractor arrangements that can and
do disappear at a moment’s notice.
China’s largest platforms can change their
contracts with drivers without their consent.
Now, that’s the most vulnerable end of
the spectrum. But even the luckiest,
most privileged workers — programmers and
engineers — are overworked and underpaid.
Some work what’s widely known in China as a “996
schedule”, meaning 9am to 9pm, six days a week.
In other words, workers are
either excluded from the labor
market — like we saw in Heilongjiang
— or abused, as in the case of urban,
highly-educated programmers. Neither are paid
as well as their counterparts across the globe.
When even the “winners” are treated so poorly,
one wonders why workers don’t complain.
The obvious answer, of course, is that
they do, yet their voices are censored.
Another explanation is that the public
only hears “good stories” about technology,
thanks to the Party’s control of the media.
Both these things are true. There’s no doubt
censorship and propaganda play a massive role.
But theories alone are no substitute
for real-world, on-the-ground research.
At some point, it helps to just
ask. And that’s exactly what
Ya-Wen Lei did for her book “The Gilded Cage”.
What she found, in interview after interview,
is that Chinese programmers are aware of their
unusually stressful working conditions. But,
they situate their personal hardships within
a larger context: the nation’s development.
One engineer said, quote, “If
Chinese people worked from 9
to 5 like people in developed countries,
we wouldn’t have so many accomplishments”
And another, “China remains a developing
country… I don't think… the government can
do anything if we want to catch
up with developed countries.”
Put differently, their low monetary wages are
offset by a kind of psychological wage — pride.
This is why Xi Jinping loves to repeat platitudes
like “the East is rising and the West
is declining” — these narratives buy
the Party incredible leeway. All is
forgiven in the name of “progress”.
Chinese tech workers aren’t exploited, they’re
part of something bigger than themselves!
Many of the darkest chapters of Chinese
history have been justified by this vague
notion of “national progress”, from the
Great Leap Forward to the One-Child Policy.
Even today, it’s widely assumed that
the latter was necessary, effective, and
helpful — three myths that I challenge in
the latest episode of my series “China,
Actually”. In it, we also explore questions like
“How was the policy enforced?”, “Who was and
wasn’t affected?”, and how does China’s birth
rate compare to nearby countries like Taiwan?
The One Child Policy was among
humanity’s most ambitious attempts
at social engineering and yet so
little is known about it today.
You can watch the entire series,
which also covers myths like that China
lifted 800 million people out of poverty
or that it’s “secretly building thousands
of underground nuclear bombs” — on Nebula.
Nebula is the streaming platform built by and
for creators. It’s also home to other great
Originals like RealLifeLore’s Modern Conflicts,
which explains many of the 21st century’s most
important wars and Wendover Productions’
fascinating series “The Logistics of X”.
Now, normally, Nebula costs $5 a month.
But you can get it for just half that by
signing up for a year with the link
on screen or in the description now.
That’s just $2.50 a month for loads
of exclusive content you’ll love.